iran is vowing revenge against israel
after blaming it for a blackout an
underground nuclear site in natanz
tehran has branded the cyber attack an
act of terrorism
various sources confirmed that the
zionist regime was behind this incident
iran's response will be to exact revenge
on the zionist regime at the right time
and place
the natanz facility suffered an outage
on sunday a day after the president
unveiled a new set of advanced
centrifuges for faster uranium
enrichment
tehran claims the attack was an attempt
to disrupt ongoing talks between iran
and world powers on reviving the 2015
nuclear deal
iran's atomic agency has said there were
no casualties or leaks resulting from
the incident
but i spoke with political analyst syed
mohammed marandi from the university of
tehran
who thinks any damage is likely to only
be temporary
one of the halls was damaged natanz
facilities has
four or five halls where enrichment
takes place and it wasn't
in the halls where they had their
advanced centrifuges the
old centrifuges were damaged in
uh seven to nine weeks they will be
producing as normal and they will be
replacing the old centrifuges
with the more advanced uh and the uh
state-of-the-art centrifuges the israeli
media were quick to
boast the outage was the work of mossad
while on sunday
the israeli prime minister had this to
say
the fight against iran and its proxies
the fight against iran's nuclear program
the fight against iran's nuclearization
is a huge task
is it possible that this could be
interpreted as some kind of admission
that means that the israeli regime is
acknowledging
that they've carried out an attack on a
sovereign country
and of course that would normally be
condemned by the international community
would go to the u.n security council
and the regime would face sanctions
obviously the europeans and the
americans will
allow the israelis to get away with that
everything but
this wasn't an act that was carried out
by the israelis alone
in in the past the israelis worked with
the cia and centcom and it is believed
that
by some that the i some of the iaea
inspectors may have passed on
information
i think that ultimately the iranians
will respond and they will
respond in a big way for a number of
things that the israelis have done
but the iranians are patient and they
are known for their patience but i think
the last 20 years
have shown that iran knows where to push
things
you